[Music]
who are you
wearing oh hi so I almost
fell this right here is YouTube life I
edited this video in the car now I'm
walking to where we need to go while it
uploads is it uploading I need reception
we were down in the garage
[Music]
P5 I'm doing well today thank you guys
for
asking so we're heading to an American
eagil styling event I'm pretty excited
Joey's going to be there just Jared is
going to be there and we're going to the
m we're going to the ma in America event
this weekend you probably can't hear me
so I'll resay this later probably unless
you can hear me when I'm
editing who are you wearing St here at
the styling session Joey how are you
look at you really good you actually
just did you just show her outfit that
was all me um I'd like to play my
roommate David who's taught me
everything I know about styling so yeah
so which outfit did you pick um I did an
overalls look then I did a dress with a
jean jacket look I just picked
everything pink that I could
find even though she likes dark colors I
know but we'll see what when it's
Festival you got to be like real bright
and Festival
is
festive that's what I'm here for thank
you I'm waiting for the next outfit
this is such an igj outfit too I it is I
love it it's so cute it's cute I like
pants too yeah I'm definitely going to
have to get those so now it's my turn to
dry on some things I'm like I've been
watching you I'm like okay she's in my
test dummy I was like all right try this
one on try this one on try this one I'm
like throwing stuff over they all I like
this I know I really like this one too
it's super cute I feel like it's a real
you know a fall transition piece a nice
back to school look you know it's great
back to school look right here you know
where's your
backpack set so did you get all your
stuff yes I did I'm so excited yay I'm
so excited to see what you end up
wearing cuz they all look so cute I know
it's awesome I'm so excited for tomorrow
and we're going to a Festival this
weekend so hopefully we'll see some of
you guys there there may be some people
here that may be going see
you okay bye hello so it's time to go
celebrate Jenna's birthday for the 50th
time look at you guys in your Turtle
gear turtle
yeah I Jenna's got us both beat though
Justine ordered me these so thank you
Justine my t-shirt is in the mail and
it's supposed to be here let's see if
it's here yet going be a real happy day
if you
open no look it's Steve look at this
basic purple we do let me let me call at
you real quick
homie my God I'm a
magician what it would you can you like
put it on the side of your
head so we can put the yeah but You' got
the purple we
cancro to your side right you're good to
go oh my gosh guys we got to go we're
going to be late's party oh the cupcakes
where's the cupcakes got yeah okay let's
get to the wait do one of you have keys
do we did you oh you did I don't have
keys I do you
do you can where you just getting out
the the things guys do we put should we
put this down Franchesco walks in
looking like a super and we look like
children in and
[Music]
I kids birthday
partyy 8-year-old party 8-year-old party
it's all for you Jenna thank you guys
this is all for you I hope you're happy
that's really great job I don't know how
to get it I think that's
goodday party planning yeah yeah come on
like Voltron I think it's good
happy hey look at you n100 you have it
in 100 too it's funny cuz I cop it off
you yours is black and mine's
white
wa I like it it's it's a great great
camera I would say how heavy that is
yeah it's heavy yeah yeah test it out
look at us vlogging testing it's heavy
the audio is really good not that bad wa
let me feel yours but as a vlogging
camera yeah it's not noticed notic
mine's the same one as his yeah that's
mine same same I think you got a good
crocheting you just told me and look how
great you look down
there it's
suie not actually from Iceland so we're
back home from our fun festivities I
didn't really film much me either I was
really busy having fun and socializing
with our friends I know it's so
weird so happy birthday Jenna I think
we're done we're done celebr we honestly
we're done we are it's official but we
still have cupcakes and Pizza in the
fridge so party tomorrow all right guys
I'll see you tomorrow love you bye I'm
so
tired get back in my
[Music]
purse